or even another country, for example, there are technologies that allow this.
That's what we call wide-area network technologies.
In this module, we're going to discuss what a lot of organizations have as a need, and
that is to connect devices across.
that is to connect devices across wide areas.
We've been talking about what a network is, and that is a bunch of devices that are connected
to each other for the purpose of communications.
But companies today have a need to connect devices across wide areas.
So if there's a need to connect devices in one city to devices across another city,
or even another country, for example, there are technologies that allow this.
That's what we call wide-area network technologies.
So there's different options that companies can use, and these are some of them.
We can use modems, although that wouldn't be very good anymore.
But there are other options.
Typically, these are some of the options that you can lease from the service providers that
have built capabilities to allow companies to connect across wide areas.
So we have dedicated lease lines as an option.
Those are lines like T1s, T2s, T3s that allow connections across wide areas.
We can also use satellite and other wireless links, like microwave capabilities.
But the problem with those is, typically, you'll have large footprints, but also a lot
of interference from nature and some other things that may impact the quality and the integrity
of the communications that are going across those wide areas.
What most companies use today is what we call data packet carrier services.
And so these are networks that have been created by the service providers themselves,
like AT&T and so on.
And what they do is they will lease connections to you across these data networks that have
been built specifically to allow connections across wide areas.
And just like anything else, these technologies have evolved.
The original data packet carrier services that were offered to us by these providers was
X25.
X25 is a data packet carrier service that sends information across the network by using
packets.
In fact, all of these are their packet switch networks, but they're meant to allow companies
to allow to connect across wide areas.
Now because X25 was the original one, it's really an older technology, but it's still
considered by many to be the best one to handle error correction and problems that you
may have in transmitting information across those networks.
But it requires a high overhead in order to achieve that really good error correction
that it offers us.
And so the speeds are very limited.
There's a lot of overhead, but it's still the best network for error correction.
In fact, what happened, if you look at this historically, is the industry created frame
relay to really replace X25.
And so that was a better technology that didn't do as well for error correction, but certainly
gave us faster speeds.
And in fact, that was replaced by what we call ATM.
How was one of the latest technologies that we've already had for a large number of
years?
Today, we have a better technology for this, and it's called MPLS.
And one of the improvements that they've made with MPLS is not only speed and quality
of service, but they can also offer us some built-in security, and this is what you want
to remember, MPLS networks will use what are called forwarding tables and labeling schemes
to ensure that, for example, our connection that we're using across the MPLS network that
belongs to a provider.
Our path that our information is using across their network cannot be touched by anyone
else.
And so the providers will guarantee that our path and the devices that are using our
path cannot be touched or used by anyone else while they're being used for our transmission.
So they can guarantee that the path that our information is taking is ours.
And so they'll say things like, you don't need to encrypt because nobody can get to your
information.
But I know companies that are using MPLS and still encrypt the information because even
though the providers will tell us that nobody can get to those paths, there is one entity
that can, and that is the provider themselves.
And just because we're paying them for a service doesn't mean that we should trust them to
be able to see our information.
And so it may be required that even though MPLS has built-in security that we would still
use authentication and encryption to protect that traffic based on its value.
Now what you want to remember about MPLS is that it uses technology that is forwarding
tables and labeling schemes to ensure that those paths are our paths and nobody can
get to them.
And that's the built-in security that is part of what we call MPLS networks for wide-area
network capabilities.